onyx jewel is trying to get his
restaurant back in order the bhaktas r
has been closed since the busty day
attack when over 100 people sought
refuge here Alex and his sister Rebecca
are finding it hard to deal with the
constant media coverage it's hard
because you just remember again and
again and again and again what happened
and
the restaurant is right on nieces
promenade des anglais the attackers van
came to a standstill just 100 metres
away the attack on this popular holiday
resort in southern France was completely
unexpected everyone is a really shocked
everyone is always saying it's a Paris
Paris and when no one never thought I
was going to happen here other kindred
Becca grew up in Nice where their family
has run the restaurant for 10 years on
bestie night they did everything they
could to bring their guests to safety in
the kitchen and in the food storage
rooms the whole scene was caught on
camera I'm just getting here and left
her when she's there and see like the
people to start around they start around
here young the people they start to
understand like we say to everybody just
I'm just getting inside we didn't know
what was going on and we were really
afraid that they were on the street and
there were many maybe three four five
with the guns everyone just came so fast
you're going to see some people falling
you see you'll see around here they fell
on the floor like here he fell on the
floor and people were working on him
like the children there's the father
with his son is breathing like really
fast because because it was afraid
over 80 people were killed in the attack
and dozens more were injured the
attacker was a 31 year old tunisian from
the north of nice local Muslims there
are devastated grieving for the victims
and fearing the impact on their
community Cespedes defeat the donee did
you if you keep saying that religion has
nothing to do with these ads these
people need to understand the situation
of Muslims wife complain are caught in
the crossfire only ultra Duda food
there's a considerable Muslim community
in nice and several mosques there are
fears that terrorist attacks will lead
to increasing tensions this gentleman
here with everything that's happened we
know what conclusions certain the people
from have more extreme views will draw
some will play Muslims for not
denouncing what's going on peaceful
coexistence in France has been hit hard
by this particular to view also me no
ponyo fungal coins your fossa there are
some holidaymakers back on the beaches
but fewer than usual local business
owners are worried about the long-term
effect on tourism in the city in the
short term Alex and Rebecca are trying
to cope with their trauma by hanging out
with their colleagues from the
restaurant
we come get it just somewhere only we
have to we have to talk about it we have
to express our filling to to cry to be
together to have people too and that's
what we do all together because we will
whip in through its and like some of our
employees also say to us now we're like
a family we've been through that now
we're like a family and the family wants
to open the restaurant again as soon as
possible to try to get back to normal
just like the whole of France